[Music]
Hey ladies I'm back here with Nika Karan
who is a holistic coach and other yoga
mama so one of the most common questions
a lot of you have been asking me is how
to get rid of that stubborn mummy tummy
I'm not a mom I've never experienced it
Nika is actually a month to two really
adorable sons she has gone through it so
she's here to share everything you need
to know about getting rid of mommy's
tummy
so Nika what can hold a month do about a
vm mommy tummy yes that's the question I
get asked a lot a lot of months after
giving birth I really worry about their
tummy it doesn't mean they feel great
and it doesn't look great and just the
soft confidence is just going down but
it really are anxious to get rid of it
the problem is that a lot of us thought
was doing different exercises like
crunches and plans and sometimes we
don't see any results yeah and then we
start asking ourselves so I'm doing all
those exercises and if nothing is
happening
the family is not budging so the thing
is we actually have to take a step back
and before we start doing any sort of
exercises we need to get our tummy check
for thing called Dian Fossey stretch
side it might sound a little bit funky
some mummies have no idea they've never
heard about it I've never heard about it
before I had my second child to be on it
but I thought deliver my second and I
was checked by a midwife it's under that
I have abdominal muscle separation which
is called the diastasis recti
so what is this and what is causing it
so basically when you have pregnant you
are growing a baby inside your belly and
there is a lot of intra-abdominal
pressure inside the timing and the
internal pressure is causing the
abdominal muscles to separate you know
that six-pack abs then you have variety
always its own age
but usually when there's so much
pressure imagine the baby growing belly
is just expanding the pressure is so
much that the muscle kind of hold the
pressure anymore and it's just
separating okay so the thing is once you
do have separated abdominal muscles you
can't start with doing abdominal crunch
or plans or any other traditional app
exercises because we can just make it
work okay so in this situation you have
to take a step back and settle some
simple exercises and strengthen your
pelvic floor to strengthen your
abdominal muscles your whole core and
then once that's done once you've gap is
a little bit smaller you can continue
with your traditional exercises
strengthening and building your money
six buy at because if I don't know you
if I were to just look at your pictures
I would not believe that you have given
birth because let's face it you have
that nice six packs okay does it always
respect it even you know after giving
birth how do you then team that no it
doesn't all right the short answer is no
a lot of time we just get self-conscious
because you see I don't moms and they
have flat tummies but the thing is after
it's given birth and your skin stretched
out your tummy will be sensitive skin
stretched out even for me when I stand
straight it looks nice and flat
but the moment I will I'll show you this
the moment I will try to burn a little
bit you'll see this little saggy wrinkly
skin it's just going to be there I think
so even though the muscles on Danny I
can feel my muscles underneath and they
are strong I feel strong in my car but
the skin will always be there and it's
always stretched out but you know what
it's alright it just it just probably
reminds me of my two little boys that
I've given birth to it will be like a
little tattoo on this skin that I
already carry with me forever so really
don't obsess with that we all will have
that the skin is never going to be the
same like you were 20 years old it will
lose some of the elasticity years and
it's nothing to worry about for me the
most important thing is to make sure you
are strong and then you actually build a
conference and the perfect lost strength
in the beginning because that's the
foundation of everything so how do we go
about checking if we have with abdominal
all right is actually very simple
exercise that you can do to check if you
have downloaded split and once we check
that then we
can determine what sort of exercise
again start with okay okay so let's get
started alright so here's how you're
going to make a simple task to see if
Giada has split abdominal all right so
first decide where you're going to bend
your knees slightly and you're going to
lift your head up as if you are doing a
crunch just gently engaging the core not
too high your back is so straight then
you're going to take your hand and see
where your body belly button is all
right so here is your belly button and
you're going to twist your hand around
and just try to see and measure here
inside is this the finger actually goes
inside okay it doesn't go inside here
Giada as a rock card okay
but typically if you have set of
dominoes and you tip your hand around
you're able to see how many fingers can
go deep inside that little hole that
little slips in your abdominal muscles
alright so to measure your fit
abdominals use your fingers and that's
the measurement say that 1 2 3 4 fingers
with when I was pregnant after my second
pregnancy the split was about 2 finger
width and normally almost 10% of women
will have any sort of separate muscle
separation usually two by one or two but
a lot of times it tends to go a little
bit deeper and now if it's just one
finger or two fingers you don't have to
worry so much usually after a few months
the muscles will naturally start to go
back together but if the separation is
more than two fingers you should be able
to you should start with certain core
exercises to strengthen your muscles and
to also help to close the gap because
bringing the muscles together and once
that done you can progress with other
core exercises
so now we are going to show you five
simple exercises you can start doing
right now
to strengthen your abdominal muscles
your core your pelvic floor and to start
closing that gap in your abdominals if
you found out that you actually have it
all right so we're going to start with
lying on our back okay keep your knees
Bend your feet slightly below your knee
and from here
your back is neck neutral we're going to
start with if you have a fall or a block
you can just bring it in between your
knees and we're going to start with
bringing your hands down and just trying
to squeeze the ball with your meat all
right by doing that you're going to
learn how to engage your inner thigh
when your inner thighs engage your core
muscles your deep pelvic floor muscles
are engage as well but it's slowly
squeezing and out and season and out and
remember to focus on your breath you
exhale just region and then you inhale
when you open up and again squeeze and
open try to do it for ten rows okay
again squeeze and ah alright this is
your first exercise now the second one
we're going to move on you're still
going to squeeze the ball in between
your knees but now you're going to add
lifting the hips of the ground into a
simple bridge pose and then squeezing as
well alright so with enjoy going to lift
up and squeeze with exhale open inhale
and exhale down good one more time
inhale exhale squeeze inhale open exhale
down all right let's repeat eight more
on inhale and squeeze and open and go
down try to really breathe it into the
pelvic floor open and go down by more
lift and squeeze open and go down four
more inhale squeeze engaged in at eyes
and go down last three inhale and
squeeze open and go down remember to
breathe make sure your movements are
mindful you don't have to rush last
round inhale squeeze open and go down
all right you could be breath in you can
remove the block or the ball okay now
we're going to move on to another
exercise so gently bring your knees to
athira Chaz hands on your knee and we're
going to drop one heel down left I'm
going to lift it up and again draw and
lift up all right slowly inhale and
exhale and inhale and exhale all right
let's do five more and exhale
angel feeling your core Johanna exhale
it's really gentle
initially you might feel like you're not
really pushing your body too hard
don't worry about it don't rush push
your body alright it took you nine
months carry the baby and take your time
to go back into your good previous state
all right one more
and on the other side and back all right
video ye and from here we are going to
move to another exercise let's just
gently sit up okay let's go back on our
all fours and we are actually going to
go on our four okay alright so just
bring your forearms down and you need to
adjust through your hips get back is
straight and we're going to start with
missing your right hip hop your knee
turn and then gently release as we drove
up engaging again core your pelvic floor
you have to go to high exhale
and each and exhale and income and
inhale another four Jen
three and two one more and let's repeat
on the other side left leg goes all the
way up and then slowly down and and Wow
awareness of your breath exhale and
inhale try not to sink your back and in
five more when and scissors slowly no
rush
make sure your muscles engage three
and two and one
all right yes and the last exercise we
are going to do is our good of what we
have to strengthen our legs in order to
strengthen our core muscles so let's get
started and so you're going to gently go
down with inhale and then slowly exhale
out and again inhale and slowly exhale
out and go down and make sure that
tucking in your tail bulges keep it
neutral another four slowly and in
inhale and one another two and one and
that's it these are your five exercises
you can start doing today if you find
that that you have split up dominoes do
these five exercises what's really wrong
it will won't take you more than ten
fifteen minutes a day and you will
really start seeing your posture and
your pelvic floor strength coming back
and hopefully you start closing the gap
and then you'll be able to go back into
your normal routine exercise version and
what should it do more office well
should it be walking a lot more every
day yes there is one thing if there's
one thing you can do to actually help
you're building that strength and also
closing the gap is walking every day if
you can go for a walk with your baby for
30 minutes up to one hour you will
definitely help to strengthen your
muscles what about moms who have given
birth more than six years of seven years
well these exercises to be effective for
them yeah that's the thing a lot of moms
are not aware that they have said and
then you're doing all sorts of crunches
and plans and all the other terminal
exercises and it's actually it's not
going to help and you're always going to
have this mummy tummy
until you go back to basics until you
close the gap so yes definitely
even about six years ago or even ten
years ago I've seen moms who are with
this amount of time since giving birth
and there is still able to close the gap
and start getting rid of that mummy Tami
with the simple exercises so mums you
can start these exercises right now at
your home do it every day like
nakiya suggested okay and Nika we can
get more information from your website
correct yes there is more information
and a step by step program is that just
a simple exercises against backward but
definitely it progresses into more
advanced ones and you can find all the
information on my website in the link
below this video so thank you so much
for watching I hope you all find this
video to be really useful do subscribe
for a lot more yoga videos with Nika and
we will be filming a lot more together
thank you and be sure to check out the
link in the description box thank you
see you next time bye